بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله واشهد ان لا اله
الا الله واشهد ان محمدا عبده
ورسوله اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا
محمد وعلى اله
واصحابه اجمعين اما
بعد يقول الله
تعالى
في كتابه
الكريم للذين استجابوا لربهم
الحسنى والذين لم يستجيبوا له لو ان لهم
ما في الارض جميعا ومثله معه لافتدوا
به اولئك لهم سوء الحساب وماواهم
جهنم وبئس
المهاد افمن يعلم انما انزل اليك من ربك
الحق كمن هو
اعمى انما يتذكر اولو
الالباب يقول تعالى للذين استجابوا لربهم
الحسنى
الاستجابه لله سبحانه
وتعالى فليستجيبوا لي وليؤمنوا بي لعلهم
يرشدون
الاستجابه
التصديق باخبار الله
ورسله
والاستجابه القيام على حدود
الله بشكل
مجمل وبشكل
مفصل
ال الاذعان والانقياد
لاوامر
الله
والانتهاء عن نواهي
منه ادنى
واجب ومنه ما
هو يكون من
المكملات يعني
مثلا جاء احد وقال انا اؤمن بان
محمدا صلى الله عليه وسلم مرسل من قبل
الله
امنت
لكن لا ينقاد لحكمه ابدا في شيء وان
دق ما
عنده
انقياد للاوامر والنواهي اطلاقا لا من
قريب ولا من
بعيد
فهذا لا يعتبر
مسلما
لماذا لان
الايمان هو
الموجب للانقياء
شو الفرق يعني بين التصديق
والايمان امنت وصدقت في لغه العرب التصديق
اشد الايمان اشد من
التصديق من ناحيه ان الايمان لا يكون الا
في الامور العظيمه
والايمان يوجب
العمل والا فلا يقال
امن لذلك ايوب عليه يعقوب عليه السلام هل
قال لاولاده لابنائه حينما جاؤوه عشاء
يبكون هل ق هل كذبهم هل قال لهم انتم
كاذبون او لا اصدقكم لا هو صدقهم في
الظاهر اليس
كذلك لكن ماذا قالوا هم وما انت بمؤمن
لنا لماذا لانه واضح في لمحات وجهه وفلتات
لسانه انه شك في
قصته وهذا الشك واضح في اعماله في اقواله
عليه الصلاه والسلام فهو صدقهم لكن لم
يؤمن
لهم فالايمان
هو التصديق
الجازم الذي يوجب الانقياد ما في انقياد
ما في ايمان لا لغه ولا
شرعا لكن هل يعني هذا ان
الانسان اذا امن وصدق واذعن وانقاد لكن
عصى الله ليس يكون مسلما بل يكون
مسلما ومن منا ليس هذا شانه
المقصود الانقياد
العام
امنت بشكل عام وهذا له اثر وان دق على
الحياه حياه
المؤمن فقوله
تعالى للذين استجابوا لربهم
الحسنى الحسنى التي هي الجنه
والمغفره والرحمه ورضوان الله والنظر الى
وجه
الله وعدم الموت في الجنه وعدم
التحريم والذين لم يستجيب
له
وممن لم يستجيب لله جماعه في زمن النبي
صلى الله عليه
وسلم
هم صدقوه صدقوا انه مرسل من قبل الله نعم
قالوا هذا مرسل نحن نعترف بذلك لكن لا
يهمنا هذا كفر هذا النوع من الكفر يسمى
كفر
الاعراض يعرض الانسان
تماما والا فابو طالب
امن يعني تصدق بقلبه ابو طالب
صدق انه رسول من عند الله فرعون صدق بان
موسى عليه السلام مرسل من عند
الله ولما وقع عليهم الرجز قالوا يا موس
ادع لنا
ربك بما عهد
عندك
ف
ولكن رفضوا الظاهر اعرضوا هذا كفر عراط
يقول تعالى والذين لم يستجيبوا له لم
يستجيبوا لله لم يستجيبوا لرسوله صلى الله
عليه وسلم لو ان لهم ما في الارض جميعا
ومثله معه لافتدوا به يوم القيامه اسال
الله
العافيه وهذا الافتداء في غير محله الله
عز
وجل لم يامر احدا من عباده بهذا
اولا
ان يكون له كل ما في
الارض ومثله معه وان يفتدي به من النار
الذي امر الله عباده اسهل من هذا
بكثير لكن هو عسير على من لم ييسره الله
عليه وقد جاء في
الصحيح ان العبد يؤتى به يوم
القيامه
ويساله الله يقول سبحانه وتعالى وهو اعلم
عبدي رايت لو ان لك ما في الارض جميعا
اكنت مفتيا به من النار اليوم فيقول نعم
يا
رب نعم يا رب
فيقول قد اردت منك ما هو اهون من من ذلك
فابيت الا
الشرك هذا لم يرد منه اصلا والله لا يكلف
نفسا الا وسعها ولا يكلف الله نفسا الا ما
اتاها يقول تعالى ومثله معه لافتدوا
به اولئك لهم سوء
الحساب فهمنا من
هذا ضد سوء الح حساب الذي هو حسن
الحساب فعنا سيء الحساب او سوء الحساب
وعنا حسن الحساب في ايات اخرى فسوف يحاسب
حسابا
يسيرا ففهمنا من ذلك ان ثم حسابا
عسير
و
حساب يسير فما هو الحساب
العسير اسال الله العافيه ما هو الحساب
اليسير ما هو الحساب الحسن وما هو سيء
الحساب سوء الحساب
العدل سوء الحساب عدل الله
التام الانسان مهما كان
طاغيا مهما كان معتديا مهما كان
كافرا
فانه سيقام عليه
العدل لن يظلم لا ببخس
الحسنات ولا بسيئه ليست بسيئه لم
يكتسبها
فالانسان اما ان ي يعامل ويحاسب بعدل
الله واما ان يحاسب
بفضل
الله العدل
والفضل ايش الفرق كل عبد فهو بين رحمه
الله وعدل
الله وجاء في
الصحيحين من حديث ابي هريره ان النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم قال ان الله تعالى لما خلق
الخلق كتب فيك كتاب فهو عنده فوق العرش ان
رحمتي سبقت
غضبي ان رحمتي سبقت
غضبي والله
تعالى يذكر انه الرحمن الرحيم وقال ومن
يحلل عليه غضبي فقد هوى واني
لغفار ف كل عبد بين هذين
الوصفين اما ان
يكون في عدل الله او في رحمه الله
في فضل
الله
الذي يكون في عدل الله فهو هالك
يقينا
لماذا لان الانسان ظلوم
كفار اصلا
والله عز
وجل
يرحم من يستحق الجنه بعمله لا
احد الانسان خلقه الله واعطاه
ورزقه وعلى ذلك
فانه كل انسان يعصي الله بنعمه الله في
ارض الله تحت سماء الله تحت نظر الله في
مراى من الله سبحانه
وتعالى
الانسان ليس له رخصه
ابدا في عصيان
الله والذي يستحقه
الله اكثر بكثير مما يقوم به
الانسان ف
فاذا الذي يناقش الحساب بعدل فانه
هلك
واما الذي في فضل الله فانه ينظر في
كتابه نظره عامه مجمله ثم يغفر له
جاء في الصحيحين من حديث
عائشه انها سمعت النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
في لفظ الطبراني سمعت النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم يقول في صلاته اللهم حاسبني حسابا
يسيرا فبعد ان انصرف من صلاته
سالته ما الحساب
اليسير
فقال من نوقش الحساب يوم القيامه
عذب لاحظوا اللفظ من نوقش من
النقاش النقاش يعني
الدقه ينظر بدقه في كتابه يوم القيامه
كتاب عماله عذب لا محاله وفي روايه من
نوقش الحساب
هلك فقالت عائشه رسول الله الم يقل الله
تعالى فسوف يحاسب حسابا يسيرا فاما من
اوتي كتابه بيمينه فسوف يحاسب حسابا
يسيرا قال انما ذاك
العرض انما ذاك العرض ايش يعني العرض يعني
ينظر في كتابه يقال له تذكر كذا تذكر كذا
بشكل مجمل يقول نعم يقول غفرتها لك يا
عبدي بشكل مجمل ليس انه كل كبيره وصغيره
يؤتى به
والله عز وجل
نسب
الكلمه التي يقولها
المجرمون عن كتبهم ما لهذا الكتاب لا
يغادر صغيره ولا كبيره الا احصاها هذا قول
من قول
المجرمين ليس هذا
قول اهل الايمان واهل الج اهل
الجنه يقول احدهم هاء مقرا كتابي اني ظننت
اني ملاق
حسابي هذا ياخذ كتابه الله يبدل سيئاته
حسنات الله يجزيه باحسن ما كان
يعمل اليس كذلك اما المجرم مالي هذا
الكتاب لا يغادر صغيره ولا كبيره الا
احصاها ووجدوا ما عملوا حاضرا ولا يظلم
ربك
احدا هذا حساب عسير اسال الله العافيه قال
صلى الله عليه وسلم من نوقش الحساب
عذب فهذه
المناقشه ياتي ويقول ما لهذا الكتاب لا
يغادر صغيره ولا كبيره الا احصاها تذكر
كذا تذكر كذا صحيح لك حسنه هنا لك سيئت
هنا و هكذا وهل مجره بالعدل فماذا يكون له
الهلاك يهلك
يقينا
الانسان لا يدخل الجنه ولا ينجو من النار
الا بفضل من الله
ورحمه جاء في الصحيح ان النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم قال قاربوا وسددوا واعملوا
وابشروا واعلموا ان انه لن يدخل
احدكم الجنه
عمله قالوا ولا انت يا رسول الله قال ولا
انا الا ان يتغمدني الله برحمه منه وفضل
هو لا
يدخل عليه الصلاه والسلام
الجنه بحقه ويدخل بفضل الله وبرمه
الله ولذلك كان العلماء من اقصى
الادعيه من
الادعيه يعني الادعيه في في كتب الرجال
العلماء علماء الجرح والتعديل في كتب
الرجال رجال قوات الحديث اذا اراد ان يخسف
براوي قال هو في عدل الله
هكذا او عامله الله
بعدله ايش يعني هذا الكلام يعني هذا كذاب
يستحق عدل
الله هذا
جرح العلماء اذا قالوا فلان في عدل الله
يعني فلان كذاب ستحق عدل الله فيه كذب على
النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم فقوله تعالى اولئك لهم سوء
الحساب وماواهم
جهنم جهنم من اسماء
النار ولها اسامي متعدده معروفه في كتاب
الله في سنه النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم وكلمه
جهنم قيل هذه الكلمه
اصلها من
الجهم والتجهم والج
هو
اشتداد
ف قيل سميت النار جهنما لشده حرها
وقيل
لشده
عمقها عميقه جدا وبعيده عن الله لبعد
قعرها عن الله سبحانه
وتعالى
وقيل كلمه فارسيه
معربه يقول تعالى
وماواهم جهنم يعني يدخلون فيها تماما وهي
ماوا لهم لا تنفك عنهم بعد دخولهم
اياها يقول وبئس
المهاد المهاد الذي هو
الفراش هذا مهاد
جعلنا ال ارض مهادا يعني
فراشا فالله عز وجل سمى جهنم
مهادا استهزاء سبحانه
وتعالى هذا هو فراشهم فما بالك بالصعب في
النار اهون
احوالها
هذا
الوصف وبئس يعني
اسوا
سوء ليس ثم اسوا من هذا المهاد
مهادا وبئس
المهاد نكتفي بهذا القدر والله اعلم صلى
الله وسلم على نبينا محمد وعلى اله
واصحابه
اجمعين
ر
even ver number
سران الله سبحانه
وتالى trans for those who resp and ad
and
acknowledge their
lord
for is
good that is good
‏parad that is good mercy in life that
is
good forg
in الله سبحانه وتالى those
respond
resp
resp is an
additional is an additional feature
‏to
person
resp but a person must not resp in order
to have aed what is me by
this
is
‏and that's it there nothing at
all that ches about his her life at all
zer this not is
اسلام
htic
الله سبحانه
[Silence]
وتعالى
الله محمد صلى الله عليه
وسلم
محمد صلى الله عليه
وسلم has a general lel of
adh even specifically a person
specifically doesn't ff everything none
of us do we all make mistakes this is
intended intended here is a
general
lifestyle
for ‏com from musl
origin
zero adh isam is very diff sit and so
الله سبحانه وتالى to a beli asone
responded
resp beli resp الله سبحانه
وتالى لذين استجا for
resp ‏so there is a level of minimal
resp in order for a person islam to
be to be considered valid there people
in time of propet الله عليه وسلم who
belied that he was a messenger believe
the قران was from الله believe that
but did not ch anything about themselves
and didn't really
care ‏what does that me said look you
know we
believe that you are a prophet you are
messenger but
relig you
know we just don't really care about it
that much not
important صلى الله عليه
وسلم if you are a prophet then you are
to virtuous for me
‏someone the
likes and if you are not a prophet or a
messenger as you claim then you are to
lowly for me to look at mean this this
way or that whether i believe or don't i
am to resp any tye
disbelief
‏everybody disb in his being a messenger
some believed there people
around اسلام محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
believe that yes he is a prophet he is
messenger i believe that his message is
in alignment with that of prev
messengers don't
care this
الله سبحانه
وت lord for them is all
good good in this life and in the
here
good
الله
life life wor
life he
says and for those who do
not
respond to their
lord if they were to have disc the earth
fill and
‏dou have all
the of treasures dou twice the
earth they
would very eer give it as a rans for
them from the
hell but of course
it الله سبحانه وتعالى
بخاري ملم صلى الله عليه
وسلم that a man of the people of the
hell asked الله on the day of
judgment my
servant if you had the earth fill of
riches would you give it as a rans for
yourself today to escape the fire and
this person will say yes
‏will
iess that refus
worships was never give that
much الله سبحانه
وتالى
‏thees treasures andes kill each other
for that they deed each other for that
they cut each other's throats
for and it doesn't just me physical
things in the earth it also means other
things that people fight over what the
earth has to offer as position and
leadership
and
‏would not be accepted from them the day
of judgment even though none of them had
that their discretion they man to make
themselves of the people of the hell
fire
why because of greed because of
arrogance because of wickedness
الله سبحانه
وتالى indiv for
them the wor of judgement and their is
that the hell
fire and it is indeed the
wor the wor
of وصلى الله وسلم على نبينا
[Silence]
محمد